como avanzaba directo aquí en Francia 24
y nos vamos hasta Venezuela para hablar
con nuestra corresponsal en Caracas
Daniela Zambrano con ella honremos en
este encuentro del que hablábamos
también en economía que mantuvieron hoy
los presidentes de Colombia Gustavo
Petro y de Venezuela Nicolás Maduro en
el puente atanasio girardot fronterizo
entre ambos países allí ratificaron un
acuerdo comercial vigente desde hace 10
años pero en desuso tras la ruptura de
relaciones del anterior gobierno
colombiano con su país vecino Cuánto ha
tardado Cuánto ha durado este encuentro
Y qué contenido tiene en concreto el
acuerdo ratificado
este fue un encuentro sorpresivo que no
duró más de 20 minutos aproximadamente
entre el presidente Gustavo Petro y
Nicolás Maduro en la frontera y
básicamente fue para revisar el listado
de los productos por preferencias
arancelarias tal y como lo decías este
acuerdo parcial de naturaleza comercial
número 28 había sido firmado en 2011
entraba en vigencia en 2012 pero no se
aplicaba por la ruptura de relaciones
entre ambos países maduro lo definió
además como un acuerdo para firmar las
bases para expandir el comercio entre
Colombia y Venezuela Gustavo Petro decía
que había que
utilizar todos los puentes fronterizos
para este intercambio comercial que
había que llenar esos puentes de
comercio también maduro propuso crear un
grupo de alcaldes y gobernadores de
ambos países para
crear una zona económica especial entre
el norte de Santander por parte de
Colombia y el estado táchira en
Venezuela fue un encuentro bastante
breve no se había anunciado la prensa en
principio se creía que era solo la
vicepresidenta delsi Rodríguez la que
asistiría en el cuarto al encuentro pero
finalmente fue la tercera reunión el
encuentro formal entre los presidentes
de Colombia y Venezuela y Daniela Más
allá del acuerdo que ha trascendido de
la reunión y en qué punto se encuentra
ahora la normalización de relaciones
entre ambos países
Bueno este acuerdo parcial no ha sido
difundido a los medios de comunicación
pero es importante destacar que justo
antes de esta reunión entre maduro y
Petro en la frontera venezolana ya el
presidente Gustavo Petro había declarado
que la reanudación de las relaciones
entre Colombia y Venezuela y la
reapertura de las fronteras no había
traído los beneficios económicos
esperados Pues el mayor intercambio por
comercial Por decirlo de alguna manera o
el paso de camiones en la frontera
Colombo venezolana sigue siendo por las
trochas ilegales y esto bajo el
consentimiento de funcionarios públicos
de ambos gobiernos Esta es la segunda
vez que lo dice básicamente tampoco se
ha podido
restablecer los consulados de Colombia
en Venezuela y de Venezuela en Colombia
El embajador Benedetti recordaba que en
Venezuela funcionaban quince consulados
colombianos y dijo que 14 han sido
desmantelados y hasta el momento no se
han podido reanudar
tampoco los vuelos directos entre
Colombia y Venezuela se han renovado
como se había anunciado inicialmente y
importante destacar que paralelo este
encuentro también
93 organizaciones no gubernamentales
solicitaron en Carta abierta al
presidente Gustavo Petro que
intentara frenar esta ley que pretende
eh
cuestionar Y controlar a las ong en
Venezuela para evitar su financiamiento